24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 les
policiers se relaie pour traiter et
répondre à un maximum de victimes
violences viols ou encore propos
sexistes en trois ans la plateforme a
doublé ses effectifs pour répondre à une
demande toujours plus forte la première
année en 2019 on a à peu près à six
mille 6000 chat reçu en 2020 avec les
périodes de confinement on est à dix
mille cinq cent pour l'année
là en 2021 à la fin du mois de septembre
on a déjà atteint les dix mille
conversation donc on sera en évolution
par rapport à l'année 2020 on est en
constante évolution sur le nombre de
chat reçu le portail de signalement est
entièrement anonyme et assure un accueil
personnalisé à la victime la durée d'un
jet dure en moyenne 54 minutes les
conversations à ne pas recommencer 230
manière différente des fois c'est un
appel au secours immédiats quelquefois
sont des personnes qui ont besoin d'être
mises en confiance qui justement nous
disent je sais pas trop j'ai pas envie
de vous déranger des choses comme ça
chaque conversation est vraiment unique
on s'adapte à ce qui nous est dit pour
répondre au plus près des attentes de la
personne 51% des quatre concernent des
violences conjugales 35 % des
infractions sexuelles et 5 % des
infractions sexiste des chiffres en
constante augmentation
soit parce que les personnes n'ont
jamais accédé aux services de police
auparavant et souhaite avoir des
conseils sur ce qu'elles ont vécu soit
parce que c'est pour elle plus facile en
fait pour ensuite avoir un rendez vous
dans un commissariat de police et le bas
voir se répéter plusieurs fois en
arrivant torche au commissariat depuis
2018 le portail de signalement de
guyancourt a enregistré 28 mille chat la
moitié à déboucher sur un dépôt de
plainte ou sur l'ouverture d'une enquête
dans un commissariat